[Musique]
Je lui dis tout le temps
parce que je sais que si quelque chose
si quatre flics noirs avaient fait à un sens
ce qui a été fait à George, ils
n'auraient pas à enseigner de nouvelles leçons, ils
n'auraient pas à le faire  obtenir des sociétés ou obtenir de l'
argent, ils les enverraient en prison et
jusqu'à ce que nous sachions que le prix de la vie noire
est le même que le prix de la vie blanche,
nous allons continuer à revenir à ces
situations encore et encore oh c'est
agréable de voir certaines personnes  changer d'
avis le chef de la NFL a dit Yale peut-être que nous
nous trompions
les joueurs de football peut-être qu'ils avaient le
droit de protester pacifiquement contre ce qui ne s'excuse pas de
redonner du travail à Colin
Kapernick le président parle de faire
venir l'armée mais il n'en a pas dit un
mot  huit minutes et 46 secondes
du meurtre par la police de George Florrick ou
il a dit que la famille avait ma sympathie et
tout c'est même donner à ceux dans d'autres
situations leur sympathie il a défié la
Chine sur les droits de l'homme mais qu'en est-il des droits de l'
homme de George Floyd
beca  utiliser il a changé non seulement ce pays
pas seulement les États-Unis il a changé
le monde
George Floyd a changé le monde et nous
allons faire savoir au monde qu'il a
fait une différence
bonjour mon nom est Brook Williams George
coule bien